My day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
So you were asking me before this about the fights this weekend.
What are you feeling?
Finger because where they were counter starker that's why they,
they keep the distance and they'd know exactly that.
This is what I think a lot of people were like pissed off.
It was boring.
But I think that's because they just want to see people beat the fuck out of
each other,
which I understand that's why you tuned into cage fighting.
But to me the way I always described martial arts is it's high level problem
solving with dire physical consequences.
And if you run in on Tyron Woodley,
you got some dire physical consequences.
He's a fucking powerhouse.
And if Woodley charges at Thompson,
there's dire physical consequences cause he was getting tagged when he would he
need set it to me after the fight.
He's like,
he caught me a few times as I was charging towards him.
So Woodley has a different style in Thompson.
Thompson has that wide stance,
that karate style and he's excellent at moving in and moving out and almost like
point fighting you.
He's just jabbing you,
hitting you with these,
uh,
clean left hands,
sliding out of the way.
Occasionally throwing kicks.
But mostly what he's doing is making you wonder what he's gonna do and when he's
coming at you and Woodley had to pick his battles and figure out when he could
launch himself at them.
So at any moment something could have happened,
but a lot of shit didn't happen.
So the people watching at home,
but that was more boring forever.
It's because those moments are so critical.
Those moments are so dangerous.
You can't just,
they would like it to be like Frankie Edgar Gray Maynard just fucking chaos or
punches throwing wild.
Not going to happen like that.
You can't do that with Wonderboy.
You can't charge at him like that.
He will fucking counter you and you look,
you will be one of those people on his highlight reel.
So Tyron Woodley was very smart and that he knew that he couldn't charge Adam
and Wonderboy.
He's not going to charge a willy either.
I mean,
he got an almost knocked the fuck out in the first fight.
He almost got knocked the fuck out in the,
in the fifth round or the second fight to Woodley's a powerhouse man.
He hits so goddamn hard.
So everybody had to be on their toes.
They both had to be minding their p's and q's.
And that translated for a boring fight to a lot of people,
but not to me.
To me,
I was like,
anything could happen at any moment in the fifth round or almost did when,
when,
when Woodley connected and Thompson's knees went out,
I mean,
he slumped,
he was out,
man.
He was out for at least a half,
a second or a moment.
You know,
there was a moment where his legs gave out.
His body went limp and they could've stopped the fight right there.
I'm glad they didn't,
uh,
glad they kept going.
I talked to a big John McCarthy in the cage after the fight ago,
how close we were to stop in that fight.
He goes,
he goes,
I wasn't close to stop.
And I fight.
I go,
what?
You were looking right?
He goes,
I was looking.
I go,
you were looking to close.
He goes,
I'll never admit it.
I go,
it was,
but it was,
I mean he was almost out right.
He goes,
he was almost out.
It might've been out for half a second,
but he,
I gave him a chance.
I know you did a great job.
He did an amazing job.
I mean that's why big John McCarthy is so important.
The guy with that kind of experience and if he fucked that up,
everybody would be so mad at him.
But he did it perfect.
It was perfect.
He has the most difficult job in the sport.
Other than the fighters.
Fighters have the most difficult job.
Second most difficult job is the referee.
Third most difficult job is a judges.
I think so,
yeah.
I believe it's going to interpret the trauma.
Yes.
40 other people.
Well he has to be,
he has to look,
he has to be at the right angle.
Like they're moving around and they're fast and they could go to his left and he
can be over here,
but something could be happening on there.
Right.
And he doesn't even see it.
You know,
you don't know.
Like sometimes,
sometimes guys don't see taps.
Sometimes guys don't see a certain I pokes or groin shots.
There's a lot of things that can happen.
A referee's job is insanely difficult and they only get praise when they fuck
up.
They only rather get attention when they fuck up.
They don't get any praise when they do a great job and just just they need more,
you know,
the they'd need more.
More people need to understand like how difficult that is.
So that moment where Tyron finally did connect on Wonderboy and everybody's
like,
why didn't you do that earlier?
Because he could've gotten knocked the fuck out.
Like that was where the opening was.
Woodley was so aggressive because he was down on the scorecards,
at least in his corner's eyes and in my eyes he was as well and he had a charge
forward and he had to connect and he did.
But to make that happen,
a lot of things have to be in place.
You have to understand one of the boys timing,
he had been fighting him for four rounds already.
He was getting a sense of what Wonderboy could and couldn't do.
He also knew the consequences.
He'd been tagged a couple of times so he knew like I can't just rush Adam cause
Wonderboy was trying to time them with that right hook.
He was standing on the South Pole position with his right leg forward.
He throws that front leg side kick to the body,
throws it really well because he,
he picks it up from the ground like low and,
and,
and it's sort of scoops up so you don't see it coming until it's too late.
It might not be the most powerful application of the front leg side kick,
but it's very,
it's very sneaky because he slides in with that foot low and then it comes up
and stabs you and you don't know if it's going to come up as a sidekick or if
it's going to go up and over your shoulders around kick.
You don't know what he's doing.
He's so sneaky.
So Tyron had to be very cautious and for a lot of people it was very boring
because of that.
But I didn't think it was boring.
Wall's happening.
I was on the edge of my seat.
I was just like,
there are moments,
there's going to be moments when the shit starts flying.
And in those moments,
that's where the fight becomes amazing.
But those guys are smart.
They're not dumb.
And the belt is so God damn important.
When you have the belt,
you get to decide,
you fight all the best fighters,
you,
you make the money.
You know,
you get the opportunities for the big money fights like the Conor McGregor type
fights.
Those only happen if you have the belt.
If you don't have the belt,
nobody gives a fuck about.
So for a guy like Tyron,
man,
that belt is everything.
For a guy like woody or a guy like a Wonderboy,
rather,
that belt is everything.
If you don't have that belt,
you make a fraction of what you make.
Like think about that fight that flight's insanely close.
It was so close.
Dominick Cruz afterwards that that's basically the same fight as the first
fight,
right?
It's like you could call if you've called the first fighter to draw,
you could easily call this fight to draw and I agree with him.
And so that means that Wonderboy and Woodley are essentially like so closely
matched stylistically that it's a wash.
Right.
But meanwhile Woodley's the one who's the champion Woodley's the one who has the
potential to fight.
Conor McGregor Woodley is the one who has a potential to fight Michael Bisping
or whoever,
who else he fights at whatever weight he fights at and that is where the money
is.
So he's the guy who's going to get the money.
Whereas Wonderboy who essentially had a draw with him prove that he was it least
close enough on one fight and just a hair under the second fight,
he ma,
he's going to make a fraction of what Woodley mix likely so that those
consequences have to be taken into consideration when you're watching these guys
fight is that they know there's a wind bonus and there's a loss.
Like if you,
if you lose,
you get your show money,
you don't get a bonus.
But if you win,
you get twice the money.
Like a lot of guys have,
the way their contract is structured,
you know,
they'll make x if they win and they'll make x plus x if they'll make x plus x if
they win.
But if they lose,
they only make x.
So they might have,
they might be getting $200,000 for the fight,
but another $200,000 if they win,
that's a giant swing.
That's a big deal.
So they have to be really fucking careful.
They don't make mistakes.
I don't like when bonuses,
man,
I don't like it.
I think those guys are trying to win anyway.
They're trying to win.
I just,
I just think like,
especially in particular in situations like that,
when fights are like that fucking clothes,
I could judge,
can decide whether or not you make an extra 200 grand or don't like,
that seems crazy to me.
Okay.